[موسيقى]
جميع الوثائق والمعاملات الرسميه لامراء
هرر كانت تتم باللغه العربيه
وبامكانكم الذهاب الى متحف عبد الله
الشريف لرؤيه هذه الوثائق بحوزه صقوق شراء
اراد تعود لاجدادي وقد كتبت باللغه
العربيه ليس هذا فحسب فموقع هرر الجغرافي
ايضا اسهم كثيرا في دخول العادات
والثقافات العربيه الى هرر بالاضافه الى
اواصر الروابط التجاريه بين هرر والجزيره
العربيه
[موسيقى]
عماره البيوت الهراريه مستمده من الدين
الاسلامي وجميع الادوات المعلقه هنا على
الجدران لها دلالات اجتماعيه ويتم
استخدامها في مختلف المناسبات مثل الاعراس
والعزاء وغيرهما ولكل عنصر هنا اهميته
الرسميه والعمليه
[موسيقى]
هناك دلائل عديده على ان هرر هي مدينه
العلم والعلماء قديما كان هناك العديد من
حلقات العلم وتدريس القران داخل اسوار هذه
المدينه الصغيره
واول ما يقوم به جميع اطفال هذه المدينه
صباحا هو تعلم القران
ويقومون بذلك طوال اليوم
حتى ان هرر في فتره من الفترات كانت تسمى
مدينه القران او الحفاظ
[موسيقى]